and now it's time for bombing reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review the Dark Knight Rises
oh my god you should your greatest movie
I've ever seen in my life
nananana nananana spoilers he's this guy
called Batman only he's not Batman
anymore
he is Bruce Wayne disabled man who sits
inside his room it has nothing it she
spits most of his time not realizing
where his money is going having killed
his people double-cross him and totally
turning his back on the people he swore
to protect uh yeah go back to Batman and
here's his camper her name Selina Kyle
and when she puts her goggles up she
kind of looks like a cat so everybody
calls her Wonder Woman so Bruce Wayne is
like I'm totally not gonna be Batman
anymore no matter what anybody says I'm
never gonna be Batman never ever ever
again don't pray a woman stole your
fingerprints oh pretty smokin I am
Batman once again so she's getting the
fingerprints for this other bad guy
named Bane who looks like mr. clean if
you use WFC an SN a night hey lippy you
could secretly answer that Knight Rises
Garrity have half the cashews so it
turns out Payne is actually working with
Catwoman who sounds like it makes a
Darth Vader and every Russian comedian
you ever heard in my country
fingerprints search for you Catwoman is
like why do you use fingerprints so we
can make him do foolish decisions with
his mummy
but he's already doing that but we're
trying to make him go bro but he's
already doing that I'll talk we need to
look ready twist like this that's
unlikely some Bruce Wayne gets help from
Tommy fur cap from the Sun and he's like
dude I knew your bed man oh when I look
at you I could just tell holy smokes I
tried so hard to be careful I mean I
drew a ton of attention to myself acting
like I was insecure and had a secret to
hide where did I go wrong
wait maybe I did disguise my voice
enough if there's ever doing it like
this the nasty I have to talk like this
nobody will recognize me if I talk like
this and everyone will be so intimidated
and not effing arias ly acne so I should
leave my mouth open more I think they'll
be a good idea
am I gonna be Robin or not technically
new I'm out of here so Batman is like
birthday he's aware time to kick some
bad ass anyway it's a trap Hey look
they're playing Wii minutes don't bring
in and Bane finally meet
so bein beats the crap out of Batman and
Bane takes them all the way to a foreign
country to put him in a prison and
babies like there is only one way out of
this prison you have to climb through
that giant hole I get a gentle you can
cleanse it's impossible no one has ever
climbed out the van dillen
okay except for one person that person
must have been super strong actually it
was a small child well that child must
have tried tons of times to get out
actually it was done on the first try
intimidating huh a prison that a small
child could get out of on the first try
and just to make sure that never happens
again we are having absolutely no guards
at this prison and then the oxygen go
into your mask is getting to your brain
since the man dressed as a bath so pain
and his minions destroy all the
entrances to Gotham and they blow up all
chums to the city and have a bomb
holding the city hostage if anyone
leaves the city we are detonating the
bomb but in your plan did you see we're
gonna detonate the bomb anyway yes so
why don't we just don't need the bomb
now because we need to destroy the soul
of Gotham giant animal did it we need to
make a clever social commentary that
everybody can see what's it that's if we
let out all the prisoners in the city it
will be chaos des in there can it go
with that saying who are you anyway
attempt the Bruce Wayne realizes he has
to get better in order to climb out
brains hole and Bruce Wayne is like my
buddy is destroyed I don't know how I'm
gonna get better just like this there
you should be finding a few bees you
mean a hurt leg from a fall to me years
to get better from and yet being
horribly beaten in my back broken every
part of my body destroy all you needed
was a little rope wrapped around my body
and you go inside
suddenly I'm gonna be better in a day or
two yeah cool
so Bruce Wayne tries climbing out buddy
doesn't make it several times so Bruce
Wayne is like what is that they're
chanting we leave tried like ten times
you never bother to ask what they're
chanting when you're trying to come out
I'm not very observant I've been to 25
times in these movies he needs rides
rides of course I had to go through a
deep psychological study a search inside
my soul to figure out how to get out of
try it without the rope okay huh that
was easy
so first wink it's out a foreign country
somehow I get back into Gotham somehow
if I scat woman somehow and Bruce Wayne
is like let's go yeah
all the prisoners from this one person
escaped and I was with him wait you were
in a male prison yeah why because I
thought it'd be better for me really
with all the plum holes in this hat your
biggest question it's time we dress
silly especially silly
so Catwoman and bam and put together a
plan that's actually kind of confusing
imagine a confusing flat device with the
director of inception and memento and
the whole city is fighting and fighting
and fighting and fighting but young
woman is like once I help you with this
I'm never coming back to help you again
I think there's more to you remember I
said this is who I am I swear I'm gonna
stand by this this is my choice I'm not
turning my girl see in a few minutes
jerk didn't see that coming but then BAM
it finds out a terrible secret the woman
he had away Enterprises over to was
actually the mastermind all along that's
right
I was the small travel clone down in the
prison but I thought what just in the
flashback you kind of looked like a
pretty adorable feminine child yes I
know this that would I was gonna say yay
are you gonna say this is you kind of
looked uh I don't know hey you had it
wrapped up right oh you were dead turns
out the mastermind the great Batman
villain behind the whole thing all this
time was some woman you never knew Wow
I always wanna see Batman go up against
some woman I never knew through the
junker screw calamus Grove Bane I want
to see some lady whose name I can't
remember
isn't that what all Batman fans want to
see I think Cesar Romero played during
the show so Batman meets up with Tommy
and he gets on some explosives count to
five that's one at the wall what go to
five in and throw that no count to three
now roses I understand what you guys say
okay count to five and throw that at the
words can't understand a bit of it I
don't Amanda with your slipper guy okay
sure yeah look I know you Bruce Wayne
once you just use your normal voice you
know it screw it I got a bad plane
really yes it you can't write in it oh
so it turns out there's no way to make
this bump stop so bad man decides it's
time to play back Jesus that's pretty
much why he does in these movies anyway
to save you by constantly lying and
dodging my responsibilities but you're
finally gonna take some responsibility
and sacrifice your life right that is
totally what I'm gonna let you believe
what a hero autopilot
come on the autopilot flies up on
everyone thinks Batman is dead and
Albert's tears over the graves of the
entire Wayne family club Michael I swore
to protect you and now you're all dead
I'm really bad at this present Alfred
travels to some sort of fancy foreign
country and we remember him seeing I
always dream that I'll be sitting there
drinking multi-cut some British and then
I look over I say yo in some lady in a
bunch of little Batman's running around
playing with each other and it turns out
he does exactly that he looks over he
sees Bruce Wayne and Selina Kyle there
did they even have a thing Kel um
Kirsten Lester steal his ticket and
another time before the world is about
to blow up and I kids anyone next to me
at that point
I guess Rosie O'Donnell but somehow this
means true love by Alfred dodging my
responsibilities once again but it's
okay because Tommy inherits the house he
finds the Batcave and it turns out his
real name is Robin oh boy this will be
the beginning of a brand new franchise
for me and no more movies what the hell
so the Dark Knight Rises is one of the
greatest movies I've ever seen in my
life
and I don't see that often and I can't
wait to see whether or not they're gonna
do a Robin spin-off in fact I already
know what they can cut it Batman and oh
I feel a cold shiver all of the sudden
this is jittery boom sing judge you got
change after I have a guy out meet us
come on J if they send a woman to a man
freeze anything they send a man to a
woman prison that made my Dark Knight
rise